[Music]
Coolio has died
he was 59 years old I had the
opportunity to make a record when I was
really young and I thought that when you
made a record you instantly got rich
when the reality set in that just
because you make a record you don't get
rich I um my head unswelled and you know
since then I've learned to Value being
able to have a talent and you know I
just
I feel blessed and you know and I know
God is watching over me according to TMZ
the rapper died in Los Angeles on
Wednesday
Coolio's longtime manager says he was
found laying on the floor at a friend's
home it was also reported the friend
called EMTs who pronounced him dead on
the scene no official cause of death is
known at this time and ETS reached out
to his rep for comment
[Music]
Coolio enjoyed massive success over the
years
including his best-selling album
Gangster's Paradise
as I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death I take a look at my life
and
whatever say is that we we are happy
that we was able to do something
that was received so well by so many
people and
um obviously it must be something good
the title song landed Coolio a Grammy
award in 1996.
foreign
I can't believe in
in being a star and I'm only a human so
that's what I do I just
walk on the ground